[Applause]
[Music]
we've all heard about the impeachment
process against Donald Trump however how
many really understand what this means
what impeachment actually consists of
and the history of this process in the
United States I can already tell you
that this process is much more complex
than a mere debate about the president's
impeachment you see the American
Constitution defines impeachment is a
tool to be used only in extremely
exceptional cases with it the
legislative power can practically
reverse the people's will will express
through the election of presidents
therefore under very serious
circumstances an impeachment implies the
overriding of the democratically elected
regime
we're talking about a process designed
for cases in which the president has
committed serious crimes crimes that
must be clearly demonstrated after a
thorough prior investigation by the
House of Representatives mainly those
crimes include cases of treason bribery
and other serious unspecified crimes
[Music]
however even with this explanation we
still need more information to be able
to fully understand how impeachment
works that's why in this video we're not
only going to talk about the curious
process we're also going to take a look
at its history and talk about past cases
of impeachment in the United States
we're going to look at the circumstances
that caused them and their outcomes and
yes why not we'll also do a roundup on
the impeachment that our current
presidents of the United States Donald
Trump is facing impeachment a key
counter way something good about
American democracy is that it was
designed specifically to limits the
power of politicians you see the curious
thing about the United States is that
both the Constitution and the US Bill of
Rights are limiting this means that if
you read the US Constitution you'll soon
realize that what it truly says helps
prevent the states or the people who
control the state from exercising
excessive power over the rest of the
citizens
[Music]
this strongly differentiates it from
most of the world's constitutions which
focus on defining the rights and
obligations of the people and this is
fundamental it's essential for
understanding the meaning of impeachment
in the US
allow me to explain the founding fathers
establish the possibility of dismissing
the President and other senior officials
from the very beginning they defined the
process as apolitical instead of a
criminal trial that way the president
could be removed from his functions due
to serious crimes without any judge
ruling for or against him at any moment
in the process
in fact the only judge present during
the entire impeachment process is the
president of the Supreme Court who's
responsible for overseeing the operation
of the political trial once it passes to
the Senate but the sentence in this case
dismissal is decided solely and
exclusively by the Senators but you
might be thinking well hang on if this
is a political process then it could be
used against any president who the
opposition simply doesn't like right
well the truth is no in practice that
isn't possible in the North American
system to prevent the process being
abused series of complicated steps were
established to not only guarantee the
completion of a justified impeachment
process but also to limit the number of
cases beginning so much so that's to
this date in the almost two hundred and
fifty years of United States history
not a single effective impeachment has
yet occurred not even once moreover in
that entire time only two processes have
been started while three if you take the
current one against Donald Trump into
accounts three in the entire history of
the country
[Music]
now how exactly does this process work
and what are the steps that lead to
dismissal well first there needs to be a
reason evidence that the president was
involved in one of the crimes mentioned
in the Constitution with this any member
of the House of Representatives can
propose an impeachment or political
trial under oath in Trump's case it was
the president of the House of
Representatives Nancy Pelosi then the
committee's responsible for
investigating the case and determining
the facts attributable to the
impeachment are designated finally these
committees write one or several articles
that voted for individually or jointly
by the House of Representatives this
step is equivalent to presenting charges
against the president's to understand
this better the House of Representatives
mission in this case is to present
charges does the impeachment or
political judgment truly begins and the
entire process is transferred to the
Senate which plays the main role in this
entire story
[Music]
so in fact it's actually there in the
Senate at the political trial takes
place in this way the Senate acts as a
court but instead of judges prosecutors
and jurors the members of the House of
Representatives act as prosecutors and
the senators as jurors
[Music]
so if the Senators vote in favor of
dismissal with a two-thirds majority
this is equivalent to a jury convicting
the accused in a normal trial a
successful impeachment means nothing
other than the automatic removal of the
president's in the transfer of his
powers do the vice president
it seems a bit complicated but really
it's all rather logical think about it
for a moment it has to be a very
stringent process so that a president
can't be dismissed impulsively like
someone grabbing a bargain on Black
Friday but now that we know how it works
the next big question is what can we
learn from the history of political
trials in the United States as we told
you earlier
besides Trump there are only two more
cases to examine those of Andrew Johnson
and Bill Clinton and in the case of
Richard Nixon well his presidency
actually ended with a premature
resignation and despite what is commonly
thought the impeachment process was
never actually started so let's learn a
little bit more about what happens in
those cases
[Music]
to impeachments one resignation and zero
removals history of political trials in
the United States is short really short
only two presidents have been submitted
to the mens neither one was dismissed
perhaps the least known case is that of
Andrew Johnson and is not surprising
because we're talking about a man who
was presidents between 1865 and 1869
but well what did this man do that ended
up with him being judged by the American
Senate
well after President Lincoln's
assassination in 1865 Johnson who was
his vice presidents became presidents
after he took command his policies moved
far far away from Lincoln's
[Music]
to give you an idea Johnson was both a
member of the Democratic Party and also
a massive racist he is someone who would
make Trump look like a poster boy for
multiculturalism and diversity yeah
Andrew Johnson strongly defended the
slavery of African Americans and
dedicated himself to vetoing each and
every one of the bills that Congress had
passed suit recognized the rights of
freed slaves he also began pardoning
generals of the Confederate States of
America who were the ones who had
rebelled against the United States by
starting the Civil War those states the
states that rebels considered Lincoln a
threat to white supremacy whose they
strongly opposed his plans who abolish
slavery throughout the country this
really did not sit well with them and
you also have to remember that some of
these states had a slave population of
49%
[Music]
but if his actions already seemed
serious wait till I tell you about the
final straw Johnson had the brilliant
idea of personally firing and appointing
secretaries for his own government
bypassing Congress's validation which as
you can imagine is not legal so now you
can get an idea of just how complicated
it is dude dismissive president went
despite all of these incredibly serious
accusations Johnson was saved by just
one vote in the Senate this single vote
prevented them from reaching the
necessary two-thirds majority he was
barely saved but he was saved all the
same in fact this is by far the closest
a US president has ever come to being
dismissed
[Music]
the next attempt came with Richard Nixon
more than a century later after the
infamous Watergate scandal in 1972 which
I'm sure you've all heard about to
refresh your memory though the Watergate
case was a scandal that involved the
President and several CIA agents who
were spying on the Democratic Party they
raided Democratic Party headquarters and
tapped calls to gain an advantage in
Nixon's re-election as president later
during the investigation it was
discovered that this illegal
eavesdropping had been controlled
directly by the White House this news
triggered calls for an impeachment
process against presidents in 1972 in
fact the thing got so serious that
literally everyone turned their backs on
Nixon and because he didn't want the
investigation to proceeds in case
dirtier issues came up because let's
face it Nixon was a rather shady
president after seven months of
deliberations he resigns the day before
the House of Representatives were to
vote on the process one day before soak
the truth is that the impeachment
mechanism was never launched in Nixon's
case I believe the time has come to
bring that investigation and the other
investigations of this matter to an end
but it was launched against Clinton Bill
Clinton a really messed up I'm sure many
of you have heard the name Monica
Lewinsky the end of the 1990s the affair
the slip the extramarital meetings
between the then intern Monica Lewinsky
and Bill Commonwealth they were common
knowledge in Washington and his wife
Hillary knew nothing about it
but don't be mistaken the reason why an
impeachment process was started against
Bill Clinton didn't have anything to do
with the president being unfaithful to
his wife not at all
the real reason or at least the reason
for which the process was justified
Clinton's lies as well as his pressuring
of others around him to also lie to hide
a sordid story that took place behind
the closed doors of the Oval Office what
I want the American people to know what
I want the Congress to know is that I am
profoundly sorry for all I have done
wrong in words and deeds and believe me
when I tell you that in the United
States at least until Trump arrived
catching a president in a lie and
forcing those around him to lie as well
wasn't well viewed not at all so now
that we've looked at past impeachments
and how they work what about Trump the
truth is things don't look very good
because everything indicates that he's
done something very serious so what
exactly are the accusations against
Trump and can this process affect him in
Trump Biden and Ukraine a juicy plot
Trump's case started a long way back and
far away as well more specifically in
Ukraine what on earth does Trump have to
do with Ukraine and why is Joe Biden in
this sections title
while the truth is that this is none
other than the latest chapter in the
often absurdist trump presidency
basically everything indicates that
Trump asked the new Ukrainian president
valo Damir szalinski directly by phone
to investigate Biden and his relation
with the gas company barista in which
hunter Biden the son of Joe Biden who is
Barack Obama's former vice president's
in one of the future Democratic
candidates for the White House was a
board member
shortly before this call Trump rose
almost 400 million dollars in military
aid to Ukraine apparently as a pressure
method this could be considered a bribe
in exchange for a favor a quid pro quo
[Music]
it doesn't end there even the US
ambassador to the EU Gordon sunland's
acknowledged being pressured by Trump
who forced the Ukrainian government to
investigate a supposed theory that
Ukraine would have interfered with the
2016 American presidential elections and
no this time that wasn't a favor Trump
which Russia is accused of having done
but to favor Hillary and you can imagine
how Ukraine's investigations are handled
especially if they're done under
pressure from Washington in other words
Trump seems to be using the US
government's means and resources to
pressure governments from foreign
countries that have more than a
questionable rule of law to dig up dirt
against his opponents it's pretty
unbelievable stuff given the seriousness
of these claims Congress decided to open
an impeachment process to thoroughly
investigate this entire matter and
figure out if President Trump bribed the
Ukrainians to gain campaign data and it
doesn't end there
apparently Trump created a kind of
parallel diplomacy with Ukraine which
lay outside the institutional channels
he used his personal lawyer Rudy Jelani
even forcing Gordon Sunland who answered
him
[Music]
so is this enough to kick out the
presidents well we don't know but what
we do know is that information keeps
being uncovered further complicating
Trump's situation information like this
new documents reveal details of Pompey's
role in Ukraine affair emails and
documents released by the State
Department support testimony showing
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo enabled
the Ukrainian pressure campaign at the
center of the impeachment proceedings
according to testimony in the
impeachment query Ukrainian diplomats in
Washington knew there was a problem with
aid as early as July 25th the day mr.
Trump spoke with the Ukrainian president
by phone and asked him to investigate
his rivals the truth is that for the
time being the Republican Party doesn't
want to turn its back on the president
under the current accusations especially
when the elections are so close all of
this could change however if what is
known in the United States as a smoking
gun is unleashed that is if information
that could bring down the president's
and that is a hundred percent proven
demonstrated and explosive is revealed
[Music]
but until that happens and if it happens
it's not what for the Republicans do
support Trump in order to hold on to the
presidency also remember that in the
Senate which is where the impeachment is
decided Republicans hold a majority as
it stands the Democrats only hope would
be to find flagrant evidence that Trump
really bribes the Ukrainian authorities
to do all that is claimed undoubtedly
this is quite the drama and we'll be
watching to see how this mess develops
but now it's your turn after knowing how
impeachment works how past cases happens
and why they happened do you think Trump
could be dismissed or will this process
and I as just another failed case and
what do you think of the political trial
processes a counterweight to the
president's power well leave your answer
in the comments below and I really do
hope you enjoyed this video please do
hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos also please do check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
but we're not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please do
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage as always I see in
the next video
what I want the American people to know
what I want the Congress to know is that
I am profoundly sorry for all I have
done wrong in words and deeds